la chocolaterie le bon gros géant ou
encore Mathilda intemporel ces histoires
de Roald Dahl ont fait le tour du monde
et viennent d'être modifiée avec
l'accord de ses ayants droits afin selon
eux que les enfants d'aujourd'hui
continuent de les apprécier illustration
dans Charlie et la chocolaterie il était
grave avant il est devenu maigre comme
une allumette dans la nouvelle version
le mot gras il se passa a été supprimé
autre exemple avec cet extrait du bon
gros géant quelque chose de tout noir de
tout noir et de tout grand de tout noir
de tout grand et de tout Mince ici le
mot noir sera remplacé par sombre même
chose avec le terme caissière remplacé
par scientifique de haut niveau
[Rires]
depuis tant que j'attendais ça ils l'ont
fait enfin moi je suis pour je suis pour
que l'on supprime ces mots discriminants
je suis pour que l'on supprime les
passages des films comme les films
Disney qui sont des attaques et pour
quand aux gens ou pas Pocahontas
terminé
alors dans Les 101 Dalmatiens mais pour
mais bien sûr avec le chien qui a les
yeux mais ça c'est du racisme
vous avez raison il faut supprimer bien
entendu mais j'attends vos arguments
Valérie tu peux me rappeler quelle est
la fonction d'un compte la fonction
exactement
un lien intergénérationnel c'est-à-dire
qu'on discute avec les enfants à qui on
raconte le compte deuxièmement c'est
faire peur aux enfants et c'est à dire
de leur raconter que la société n'est
pas toute rose et que l'on peut ensuite
en discuter et c'est exactement ça la
fonction du compte le Petit Poucet c'est
quoi c'est des parents qui vont
abandonner leur mômes dans une forêt tu
crois que c'est drôle peau d'âme Peau
d'âne c'est quoi c'est on parle pas des
histoires on parle des mots qui sont
morts par exemple ça parle de l'inceste
peut-être c'est un père qui va se passer
donc mais donc dans Peau d'âne on déduit
le corps et on dit pas que le père veut
se taper ça peut-être sa fille non elle
est pas par exemple
j'imagine que les gens de petite taille
Blanche-Neige et les 7 pas c'est pas
leur compte préféré et que peut-être
qu'il faut avec le temps que c'est bah
voilà
comment tu sais que passe partout il
adore blancheur
avec lui et alors c'est quoi ton préféré
ah dis-moi en vrai les gens qui ont des
handicaps qui sont différents ils aiment
qu'on les traite normalement ils aiment
pas qu'on les traite avec pitié avec
quand on fait tes peines et on verra
tous vous pensez qu'ils ont pas envie de
rire de leur handicap moi j'ai une mère
qui malentendante qui sourde elle adore
qu'on se fout de sa gueule sur le fait
qu'elle entend pas elle veut surtout pas
qu'on la voit une meuf qui est
malentendante Daniel
avec les enfants justement si ces
passages là
de supprimer en fait c'est la dictature
est-ce que tu dis les passages et tout
ça et les histoires ok mais là remplacer
noir par sombre excuse-moi dans cette
phrase on parle pas de racisme du tout
c'est en voir là où il y en a pas sur
des mots comme ça on trouve ça mais d'un
ridicule achevé je ne veux pas vivre
dans ce monde je ne veux pas vivre dans
le monde
ah bon ah bon alors attends
je suis tellement d'accord avec toi je
te dis je suis en train je me dis non
mais le résultat
dans dans le vocabulaire français le mot
noir est souvent lié à des choses
négatives bien sûr et c'est ça qu'il
faut changer bien sûr c'est ça j'ai des
idées noires
c'est pas positif donc bien sûr faut
avancer un peu là dessus et on va
s'abater on va mettre un petit peu de
temps il dit enlever des mots des contes
ça le dérange pas voilà complètement
changer les comptes et ça le dérange
voilà
je comprends après on place où le
curseur parce que qui juge ce qui est
offensant ce qui c'est l'auteur
ça a été fait en Angleterre mais ça
n'est pas fait en France parce que les
autres les ayants droits disent on va
l'adapter en fonction des pays non
pardon alors ce qu'on supprime pour tout
le monde parce qu'on est surpris on est
rétrophe avec des gens comme vous en
avance pas
il faut dire les choses
et bien sûr Daniel Daniel pour d'autres
raisons de survie ok oui bonsoir et bien
moi pour une fois je suis d'accord avec
Gilles
moi je trouve que Gilles il a pas dit
que des conneries
et pourquoi moi je vais je vais même
encore aller plus loin je trouve que à
l'âge adulte à l'âge adulte quand on
regarde des dessins animés franchement
ça fait hyper peur c'est hyper anxogène
moi je ne peux plus regarder Dumbo je
peux pas regarder laissant un dalmatiens
[Rires]
les gens
la vérité la dernière fois je suis
d'accord avec elle il y a des trucs qui
peuvent faire peur
c'est normal je suis d'accord je suis
d'accord et il y a des trucs voilà qui
me plaisent pas voilà il y a des choses
à revoir des choses à revoir on voit
qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes sont de plus
en plus agressifs peut-être qu'il
faudrait même dans la même commencer par
les dessins animés parce que c'est hyper
anxiogène je pense que quand les parents
regardent les dessins animés que les
enfants nous on le voit pas la même
manière il a il est mort le bateau
[Rires]
s'arrête c'est impossible c'est
impossible c'est impossible là il y a un
replay c'est obligatoire Albat Tom alors
que l'auteur vient de décéder quoi ah le
batteur
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
merci Cyril à bientôt
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je connais pas le conducteur Benjamin
[Applaudissements]
jamais devant le fait excusez-moi
vous êtes le monsieur qui qui bonsoir
qui enfonce les auteurs de mangas
c'est ça ton problème c'est ça ton
problème en fait c'est une amie
[Applaudissements]
du fin fond de l'univers
Cyril on peut en parler qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé dans ta tête au moment où ta
langue a fourchée comment est-ce qu'on
passe de Albator à Albator
tu pensais à quoi parce que non je
voulais faire non j'ai rien parce que
j'ai pensé et en fait c'est parce que
voilà j'en avais parlé un ami et je lui
avais dit et voilà donc voilà je pensais
à le batteur voilà parce que j'aime bien
mais non parce que voilà j'aime bien
j'aime bien tout ce qui est voilà j'aime
bien tout ce qui est dessin animé moi
aussi je regarde Dumbo le weekend
[Rires]